bon aujourd'hui dans le studio on va
vivre dangereusement parce qu'on va
tester sa un hoverboard ça fais eaton
[Musique]
bon l'autre jour on m'a proposé de
tester un hoverboard alors je sais le
overboard c'est pas tout nouveau c'est
déjà sorti rien vous apprendre
probablement de neuf là dessus mais moi
j'avais franchement envie de tester donc
je trouvais ça cool quand on m'a proposé
j'ai donc accepté d'en tester un c'est
lourd d'autant plus que je sais pas si
vous avez suivi mes vidéos le jour quand
j'étais à milan j'ai testé un hoverboard
qui était franchement hypra coule donc
je suis plutôt content regarder ça avec
vous aujourd'hui
donc l'idée de cette vidéo est faite en
mai donald d'ailleurs il vous passez le
bonjour c'est l'idée de cette vidéo ça
va être de vous présenter ce poseur
board
on va le détail et dans quelques
instants de faire un petit tour
ouah ça fait longtemps que j'ai pas vu
des manuels aussi grand alors faites
voir ce qu'est dans la boite chargeur
whaou qui est pas mal
regardez moi ce truc les pneus font pas
du tout rigoler bon ben on va les tester
ça oui
[Musique]
alors sans d'abord de là il a une petite
particularité plusieurs particularités
ou la toute première c'est que vous avez
de la musique embarqué alors la leçon ne
vient pas du tout de mon smartphone mais
vient directement des haut parleurs
qu'on peut trouver sur le overboard ce
qui vous permet de vous balader en ville
où vous voulez tranquillement et de
profiter de musique dans tous vos
déplacements
[Musique]
ce qui fait que vous avez votre musique
directement sur votre sauveur bord vous
balader en vie ou vous voulez vous avez
la musique avec vous quand même regarder
si vous êtes très très très très très
bas l'aise mais alors là vous êtes
vraiment et qui veulent que vous balader
avec votre smartphone à la main vous
regarder vos vidéos et en même temps
vous avez le sont directement intégrés
et il ya un deuxième point positif à
sauveur board par rapport à plein
d'autres horreurs bande c'est la lumière
alors on pourra me dire c'est un point
de détail mais moi je trouve ça cool ce
sera plutôt joli d'avoir une lumière
séduisante sur son hoverboard je vous
montrais j'ai de la lumière sur le
devant comme vous le voyez ça c'est des
petits farcis vous êtes à l'extérieur
j'ai donc les petits éclairage ici pour
repérer un peu où je vais mais j'ai
l'éclairage sur le côté et là ça claque
un peu qu'est ce que vous en dites
mais lorsque vous vous déplacez en ville
moi je trouve ça génial alors attention
vous n'allez pas pouvoir prendre des
cailloux aller n'importe où avec ça
parce qu'au bout d'un moment vous
risquez de vous faire mal mais cette
petite déco je trouve plutôt cool on va
aller voir en extérieur on va attendre
que la nuit tombe
vous allez voir mon avis ça va vraiment
claqué
[Musique]
alors je sais au début quand on teste un
hoverboard s'est tout de suite un peu
laborieux on n'a pas forcément les vents
et pluies on se casse un peu la gueule
il ya cinq minutes d'apprentissage
vraiment cinq minutes et ensuite on est
parti pour des kilomètres on peut aller
loin on peut se balader à l'origine en
studio toujours un petit peu ric-rac
d'autant plus que j'ai ma moto qui est
juste là on va éviter de se la prendre
c'est quand même assez précis à piloter
un parce qu'au début je me suis dit
comment je vais faire ça hop je suis
coincé je tourne je peux vraiment aller
dans tous les recoins
on va éviter de se faire mal on peut
aller dans tous les recoins
qu'est-ce que j'ai la tension mais c'est
passé à sa passe pas vraiment je peux
tourner facilement on peut se décrire
ces eaux là on va sinon bon règle
générale ça se passe plutôt pas mal
faut juste faire attention aux cartons
aux motos aux voitures aux piétons très
attention en fait vraiment attention là
vous rouler et sinon si vous avez envie
après de faire des figures vous pouvez
faire des figures vous faire plaisir
c'est super cool sur ce modèle qui est
quand même très très lourd vous pouvez
l'utiliser pour faire votre muscu si
vous voulez mais là franchement vous
allez vous faire mal
vous avez des pneus en caoutchouc de 6,5
pouces je trouve que la finition est
super bien fait adapté même si vous
prenez des petits cailloux qui pleut ce
que vous voulez vous n'allez pas vous
casser la gueule ça c'est cool deuxième
point vous avez tout un châssis est fait
en aluminium qui lui donne effectivement
à côté hyper robuste super super lourd
bon il ya la batterie qui fait le point
mais a pas que la batterie tout un cadre
extérieur en plastique des anti dérapant
pour mettre vos pieds c'est minimum
sinon ça ferait savonnette
donc ça c'est aussi super cool vous avez
une autonomie de 10 à 15 kilomètres donc
franchement vous avez de quoi faire
avant de tomber en panne de batterie
vous pouvez rouler à 15 km heure maximum
alors je me suis pas encore amusé parce
que je suis pas encore un expert 15
kilomètres heure mais déjà je peux vous
dire que ça va quand même super vite
il faut savoir vous avez un moteur dual
de 350 watts
sa femme a probablement au plus
technique d'entre vous pouvez monter des
pentes allant jusqu'à 15 degrés toujours
faire attention sinon peut se casser la
gueule petites astuces de monsieur greu
toujours descendre par l'arrière jamais
par la banque voilà ça vous évitera des
déconvenues pour le recharger c'est
super simple vous avez juste ça va chier
dessus et ça marche extrêmement bien
voilà construit
un peu à part aujourd'hui pour vous
présenter ce overboard moi je trouve ça
cool je précise que ce n'est pas du tout
une vidéo sponsorisés j'avais juste
envie de tester de me faire un peu
plaisir avec ce produit si vous avez
envie d'avoir le même overboard que moi
qui fais de la lumière de la musique qui
va à 15 kilomètres heure qui permet de
monter des pentes je vous ai mis un lien
en bas dans la description et coûte
quelque chose entre 195 ou 199 euros 36
à peu près ça voilà dites moi ce que
vous en pensez en commentaire est ce que
vous avez déjà en vue lors que vous en
avez déjà eu un et est ce que celui ci
pourrait vous tentez vous ne marquez
tout ça est bien évidemment on reste
connectés
soyez sages pour les sens et vous vous
embrasse
[Musique]